cette petite pâtisserie de saint-amand
puiser vit peut-être ses derniers mois
trente cinq ans que sylvie années denis
pasquet sont installés ici
mais fin juin le temps est venu de
passer la main en recherche d'un
repreneur parce que c'est la retraite
voilà ça se termine ça fait déjà deux
ans que on devrait être encore très mon
mari est donc voilà on recherche pour le
moment pas de successeurs ont vu
pourtant tout ici est opérationnel
entretenu et renouveler au fil du temps
le fort six plaques briques réfractaires
ok voilà et puis après disons la
congélateur 9
depuis deux ans de tous deux trois ans
j'aimerais bien le savoir transmis le
commerçant et puis le lensois
parce que je suis en retraite disons et
puis je suis très fatigué alors voilà à
saint-amand la perspective de voir
disparaître un petit commerce de plus
inquiètes clients et habitants du centre
c'est le seul pâtissier qui est ici à
saint-amand autrement c'est la
pâtisserie industrielle alors c'est
terrible quand même c'est l'âme c'est la
joie des gens qu'ils y vivent
ça leur évite ça leur évite de faire des
kilomètres pour aller chercher une
boulangerie une pâtisserie dans la
nièvre 28 commerces ont été repris en
mais la chambre de métiers on recense
encore 43 que leur propriétaire cherche
à céder particulièrement en zone rurale
effectivement on constate ya moins deux
reprises dans des secteurs ruraux mais
il en est que ça peut être plus
avantageux de reprendre une entreprise
dans ces territoires on peut bénéficier
de certaines exonérations d'impôt ou de
cotisations
ces transmissions la chambre de métiers
cherche à les facilités notamment grâce
au dispositif trans entreprises
je vais du coup proposer un diagnostic
transmission donc on va se revoir
donc je vais passer une journée
finalement
dans son entreprise ses prestations
d'accompagnement de diagnostic et de
conseils sont facturés entre 150 et 400
euros
des outils pour tenter de ne pas voir
toujours plus de commerces fermés